another mom from Guatemala couldn't hold
back when she saw her seven-year-old son
for the first time since they were
separated at the border the mother and
child were reunited just hours ago in
Baltimore she is actually suing the
Trump administration officials for
splitting them up Buju Jang is in
Maryland with the reunion we should good
morning good morning or be atsume he ma
he says she and her son arrived to the
u.s. border after a three-week journey
2,300 miles by foot she says they were
seeking asylum fleeing violence in
Guatemala and domestic abuse but she was
detained and for more than a month Mejia
Mejia says she had no idea where her son
was Beata Mejia Mejia sobbed as she held
her son for the first time in more than
a month Mejia Mejia and seven-year-old
Darwin were separated in May after they
crossed the border near San Luis Arizona
seeking asylum but asylum seekers must
go to an official port of entry to enter
the US legally something Mejia Mejia did
not do Mejia Mejia and Darwin were taken
to a detention center in Arizona can you
describe the moment you realized Darwin
was being taken from you cuando one day
they called him by his name she told us
and took him away we asked Darwin about
what it was like inside a Detention
Center Darwin were you scared did you
wonder when you would see your mom again
mejia Mejia filed a federal lawsuit
Tuesday against several government
agencies and Trump administration
officials seeking a court order
releasing Darwin into her custody on
Thursday the Justice Department agreed
to release Darwin what are you most
excited to do now that you're back
together where's Luciana call me I just
want to talk to him she said it's been
so long the family's lawyers tell us
Darwin claims he received shots while
inside that detention facility he will
now get a medical check-up including a
full blood test meanwhile Mejia Mejia is
out on bond as she waits for her hearing
on her Asylum status set for August and
that lawsuit of hers is still open
John we J thanks nice to see those
reunions you know we've talked a lot
about the policy mess-up that's the
people aspect and where Darwin looks
like he has been traumatized doctor told
us earlier this week that these kids
have certainly at this age that what it
will do is cause lifetime could could
cause lifetime
drama and trauma to them and I think
that's exactly what you're looking at
you know you have a lot of parents we
get anxious when you drop your child off
at daycare for the first time yeah or to
school it the first time I mean we even
know where they are and who's taking
care of them imagine how this mother
feels but it shows you the universal
love language of parents when they see
their children yes you're looking at
inexcusable what's happening